what's up everybody welcome to
gamespot.com slash III the GameSpot
cross kind of funny stage I'm one of
your hosts Greg Miller alongside the
pride of Long Island Cal Moriarty here
we are Greg here we are Colin we've made
it we ready three whoo - [ __ ] over
there the pier when Tim jetties lets him
host now we're gonna talk about it let's
talk about this for a second
this is [ __ ] crazy you know if you
didn't know ladies and gentlemen we're
kind of funny we're a bunch of YouTube
podcasters who do stuff we used to work
at another website and we quit in
January to come out and do our own thing
and then GameSpot hit us up and said hey
we have an we have our own stage we have
another stage do you want the other
stage and we said yeah sure we do so
they gave us this awesome stage the
GameSpot Cross kind of funny stage our
logos are crossing up and I know our
logos are on the e3 show floor
prominently in the knick scarpino
designed this smiley face logo next car
pino designed the one up there this is
dick right here that's Nick everybody he
designed these logos at our kitchen
table when we quit our jobs and weren't
sure if we'd have healthcare and now
here we are
there's Microsoft this is back there
with the various kind of motors the
garbage truck we're right oh my god with
the big hug oh my god Cisco's name Cisco
we to get you we're gonna get you right
here what you're putting in the middle
well we got to get the mics up there's
no better way to start URI is to have
Cisco oh yeah yeah well we're gonna get
into the Hat Cisco
don't you worry one second about the
head there's plenty to say about the
fact that Cisco is here Cisco is doing
all this stuff is amazing
kind of funny lives you I like that you
think you might you might have watched
our stuff over on twitch.tv you might
have watched us over on any kind of
funny calm and said man usually they're
a garbage truck on fire but now they got
production values there on the show
floor I'm sure everything's gonna be
different nothing is going to be
different the quality of the video is
better we look better I am dressed
better but I assure you everything is
going to be complete
insane we hope you join us the entire
time
Cisco how are you I'm great man now I'm
gonna coming into this dingle-dangle cuz
they said right away I see your these
are your kind not really no because
that's a thing yeah but I hold a
microphone because um I usually break
these microphones so I break this one
ladies and gentlemen get up here you
coming up here what are you doing you
big lug get on up here yes sorry you're
fine you're fine
you're a prince here oh one can never do
it I'll beat it I'll do that yeah what
you got some gifts do you get it now
Cisco why are you bringing us gifts
there was a perfect past it was a
perfect pass don't think on the way of
it yeah Cisco ho you're too good to us
shirts we got game oh we do
it's a a new a new podcast sponsored by
kind of fun thank you so much just going
out there thanks for having me man BAM
I knew what it was in my house yeah
Cisco here's the thing okay when we said
we're going to e3 Cisco is coming with
us he's gonna be our correspondent all
Tuesday a lot of people said Cisco to
which I say you sent me your game list
the things you wanted to see here it was
a pretty extensive list this guy is the
realest gamer oh my god the first game
he wants to see from Nintendo is
Xenoblade Chronicles
like in your top Xbox game cuphead yeah
I was like Oh art-style right but of
course I was like hey this is subject to
change cuz once you get there they
always have these secret announcements
yeah everything so now I got like a
whole new list so see uncharted 4 behind
yeah you're seeing all your Nintendo
stuff you have a hold a book for it we
will come here you make use of Cisco so
now we've established your gamer hood
yeah it's time to get into this and we
started with usually you do these
conferences right and you're over there
with your hoity-toity websites with
their things and like we're gonna see
all the games and then we're gonna pick
game of the show yeah kind of funny said
to hell with that break up the new wife
we're starting right away we're gonna
start going like this guy here we'll put
it right there right our building we
love whiteboards I'll hold it for you
you can write people's names on it and
stuff like that okay we have the work
that I haven't seen yet we're so this we
need to turn on Nick's car penis my boy
fresh two seconds show the show the
pretty world your face kind of funny
this is what it is so there's no marker
back me Kevin Kevin tell Greg through
the magic device where the markers are I
think they're in the blue bin right
behind you
little blue pin it's right behind where
cisco sitting it's literally right it's
right there kind of funny bucket we got
black you want to use black um writing
names yeah you'll see we brought the
entire blank board here okay so we're
gonna get right into a Colin okay how am
I gonna do this
maybe you hold it now right alright
we're gonna do in here we're gonna go
okay kinda funny game of the show I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do logo oh look
at you always act like it was so hard
okay you make it look so simple Greg I
tried everything
all right so here's where we go now
we're gonna we're gonna put out our
things I think everyone gets five by the
way I know Nick I was gonna relax yeah
you know what what is you're all bent
out of shape just cuz we had your
security trying to get Cisco in here
I want to know about that having a lot
of [ __ ] right for being incompetent yeah
and this today no no difference so
everyone knows obviously when it would
be kind of funny without supper
technical difficulties but Kevin is
doing an extraordinary job over there he
is stressing like crazy he said I'm
making him call a live show he's never
done this before in his entire life I
gave him five minutes of preparation for
this and I mean if this makes it to the
Internet I'll be mystified all right all
right I'm not giving you your own slot
that's fine you worked hard last night
and you only play axiom verge right the
only game you need to remember from the
last bus ride and so Maddox torpedo I'm
giving you one of yours okay Nick axiom
verge av all right put it right there so
that everybody knows that yeah all right
that's game show do we have the extra
markers that will start building this
app where'd I put the bag oh it's right
here Greg I got it so we get to identify
r5 I really didn't the list is what they
call building noise all right there's
your five
Thank You Cisco what color would you
like here we have we have black red and
green I'll do black
I mean ray-ray right okay there we go
Greg you're fine Greg would you like
green or black this announcements or
games that are at the show we don't even
know it's at the show of course people
are hiding stuff all day long
oh so something to change it up and do
it this is the pre-show ranking
gotcha gotcha all right let me see
absolutely cool to me which which I was
tripping off of right the UH what is the
one the Disney infinity starving oh
right right right now that now that
Disney owns everything it's kind of like
a new Star Wars something that it was
Star Wars something something with a
with infinite an exact title
oh yeah the phone that looks that
trailer wasn't oh wait okay so ever the
Game of Thrones field meets like
Terminator girl games all right so so I
so far my list yes uncharted I'm fallout
4 it started off the list okay
uncharted 4 horizon okay colin has
fallout horizon cuphead mario maker
our horse maker whait way a quick
question yeah um they showed a little
bit of Mass Effect Cisco there's no rule
there's no bosses no one is watching us
we own this company yeah sure yeah we go
in no order we got Super Mario maker
uncharted okay
cuphead okay real that game looks are
you kidding me no I know I know it's
impressive but it looks amazing yeah
yeah I guess the what was that OH Super
Mario maker was
yes I missed a c7 remake I don't care
about announcement alone one the show
for me
now then transformers the Platinum oh
yeah bad if you like transformers this
is everything you've ever dreamed up hey
okay okay okay okay
it's destiny a new game or you can do
that got some new shoes definitely just
the DLC just got some new shoes new DLC
yeah last entry on the board so far The
Last Guardian question do you have the
awards yes yes they're here you prep me
one of mine right now do I mean it's you
I'm not doing anything would you like me
to actually hold the boar sure I'm gonna
need you to hold the board right now yes
you might have to get off because we're
about to get Cisco sentries no bosses we
can do whatever I want
we're doing Game of the Year or game of
the show right now we're already
building out our list what was going to
happen is each one of us has three
placards to give to a game that we
approve of right this is my placard kind
of funny approved it's my face people
will put this on their booth people will
be blown away they will walk by and go I
can't believe the kind of funny let me
put this on now Cisco don't worry we
didn't leave you you got a face BAM so
now we each f3 because we're here three
days you have one because you're here
for the one that you pick at the end
however right now ladies and gentlemen
I'm gonna give away my first ever kind
of funny approved award it's going to
Herman Herman Hulk's get over here
ladies and gentlemen
guerrilla horizon is on my list oh
that's you you're on one of my things no
prob exposure coming right turn around
turn yeah hold on right there together
Hartman host everybody guerrilla games
getting the first ever kind of funny
noise
you go put that on your booth you let
everybody know kind of funny things it's
good he's not he's definitely not what
it looks so great dude we're so stoked
I'm so glad you're doing stuff I'm glad
you're on Twitter that's a big thing no
it's put it on your booth it's on you
you want to say something you want to
say some well you don't know all that
don't it's not on yet it's one of the
stick microscope yeah no Kevin's doing
it Kevin's on it the treatment we own it
oh we limit I don't think so Kevin's
gonna tell me Jack Cavanaugh this one
yes you cycle off for one second we'll
bring up when Harmon can sit in your
seat he can give okay so I'm good hold
on can you drop this Mike there's Mike
Nix Nix Nix in and out Nick's crazy
this goes building his game now jump in
there two seconds you can go to your
real demo when it's time to boom Herman
host nice to meet you Herman is what I
like to call in OG dev okay I've been in
this thing eight years covering Sony
he's been nice to me when I was in
nobody and now that I am the best video
game journalist on the planet know what
it's been my my lifelong dream to have
Greggy Miller's kind of funny face
oh my game horizon zero dawn hosting
this face it's gonna be incredible when
the game ships I expect us to be game of
the year on the back a little war there
now as I can already tell you of course
game of the show we've opened up the
board now they'll be gone well Vic has
only played acts in the first so he's
saying actors we should already gave
okay that's true that's true you know
what stop it
get out of here no but I want to show
you already we Cisco still tabulating
whose boats over there that's one man
the pleasure bring people together
that's what we do here kind of fun now I
have you here
these are no particular order of course
I'll do a random order you're one of my
fight I can see that there it is got you
on one of his five nice Tim of course is
the Nintendo superfan you're the first
step we're kind of funny Greg approved
aboard arrives and everybody Oh big
shock that Greg Miller's first game is a
PlayStation 1 this shows going as well
right I'm just gonna keep this mark I
feel like I'm gonna be jumping off the
stage a lot at some point someone's
gonna want Starbucks me so I'm gonna go
get a run for everyone thank you maybe
like 15 minutes got it so racing this
thing right there look I'm barely
legible because I'm used to writing my
temperature oh yeah it's kind of kind of
got it I'm surprised that you're because
you've signed so many things that your
hands still work look at three or four
of us so far can I also can we take a
step back and look at everyone's
handwriting compared to Cisco's it looks
like you're all four-year-olds I'm
Cisco's like a god it's like calligraphy
he wrote it with one arch and I know
exact what it says Francisco so far yep
Tomb Raider this is the first-ever
iteration yes of kind of funnies game of
the show all right wait great did you
not pick one yeah I got caught up I saw
Herman okay
and I want to leave it open I saw you
can change now don't get now don't get
crazy well I just want to show the
people okay don't want them to know so
you know the kind of funny games did
that stick out of the kind of funny oh
it did stick last night I was watching
some people like it some people come
with scream cuz like we don't want to
force the news a lot the people to find
it organic when people yell things at us
on the street scape Jose Francisco hey I
think I was making the same face yeah I
have but it was way back when we was
first coming out oh wow and I was here
just throwing a little bit with Nintendo
but that was the first and only time
every other time I've been kind of busy
we actually came straight from my
hometown Baltimore shadow to Baltimore
Baltimore last night and we're here
today that's why I was with juice juice
boy fest fresh we are fresh does just
want to come up on stage right now with
me see everybody juice boy fresh look at
the tearaway guys they're getting down a
juice boyfriend if I thought we could
get them up here without taking down all
the equipment not only is do some a good
friend and a great dancer he's also
choreographer and man he goes all over
the world with me we just got back from
China it was amazing you can literally
like do a flip right here you'll be
surprised man I've seen him like run up
like a 20-foot wall edge
I'm gonna keep a list for now okay I
like it okay yeah it's a solid list I
still want to see what nintendo is gonna
do well they said no they have the
direct this morning
they showed about that it was due B they
showed star fox star so what we're doing
Cisco for us is we're sending you out to
see all sorts of games Nintendo you're
seeing Tomb Raider seeing uncharted at
the end of the day you're coming back
and doing a stand-up with me to talk
about which one you're picking all right
like a few times back here you tell us
about each game you can you'll give out
your award definitely we do that now
what's how much time we got here huh do
you not know I don't want this going to
be late here's I'll tell you this right
now no wait wait wait no here's the
funny thing about late outside of the
fact I'm I'm black
we were driving coming off of the
expressway
I saw the Convention Center am i cool
we're going to make it right on top wait
wait wait we had to get off the freeway
come back here's what we got to talk
about I'm used to been in the hills
Sony is very very excited to have you
come play Uncharted for us the
developers are very excited to have you
come play Uncharted for awesome their PR
person was like if he's with you we
expect them to act as professional as
you do like ice cream oh I think don't
be like what do I think it was way not
yet not to have me yellow and B so you
sit there if they applaud me on the comp
play like they do in Japan right when we
perform in Japan they're like this
silence people will come and sit people
down if they stand up yeah juice boy
fresh thank you for coming up yeah I
love you very much
Pino is coming back up always be back
appreciated - oh I'd love a water I'll
wait till after he's a pro he's a
profession I never drink or eat while
performing really this is a performance
I know you're a musician - do you eat
before a show no I'd get really nervous
all right I couldn't not nervous but job
Kevin
just you know when you cool and you're
dancing to all of that I was just
playing Trump's I was just sitting down
it basically as I don't need that energy
yeah you do you do yeah that's the heart
and soul of the band man the drummer man
thank I appreciate that he's you're
drunk
police singer what do you base your just
will kill it I'm not a very good dancer
but I feel like I could back him up you
know what I mean like just be there to
spot him if he has a runnable like when
you know when the girls are trying to
get all up on that I'll get their names
and numbers form will sort them in line
from hi I'm good excellent managing
things with the exception of this show
and the it is going so a guest from the
other stage he's right there see how I
got him out nice and I got him out
quickly right all right
nobody's firing Greg Miller today here's
the next thing yet make fun of Kevin a
lot yeah we give Kevin a hard time
uh-huh Grayson now you're the new Kevin
this whole time we're gonna be yelling
at you you're our production assistant
we're next my managers Kevin too so I
would never insult you come back our
tale it was hack Kevin in the back
Grayson what's gonna happen with you is
that I want you to escort Cisco and his
people up to the Uncharted room awesome
it because you know where to go it's 504
got it all right all right well thank
you so much Cisco you're supposed to be
back here at 120 if you're not back here
I can hold on to it I can hold on to it
unless you want to carry it around oh
all right so take you to the line and
then bring him back you come right back
but Cisco tell him on the way there he's
got to be back here 120 or at Tara's
face in half no don't say that ask him
politely to be back by 120 yeah of
course don't be polite
no Cisco doesn't respond to politeness
your response Cisco only Cisco only
dammit Cisco's here this is the kind of
stuff we have for you all day on
gamespot.com slash III ladies and
gentlemen